you'll get your other way back
he's got great touch that leakage is
great vision and really for a big guy
bump can pass the basketball fines for
fines for got two guys gonna surround
and just up and quit will hook pass
around
Randall Forex hit me heaven o 12 two
runs ever please the lane to yogi
[Music]
that's as good a pass as you will ever
see from a bit Nikola yogic this guy has
eyes in the back of his head
20 years old he's going to get better
folks the other one he had Scott this is
unbelievable they're watching Yogi's
they're not even thinking about what
[Applause]
let's get some stuff folks
yo kitch will shoot no you give it
together watch he'll get finds it goes
in with a guard but to behind the back
and we've already seen that this year
and then watch this wide open three let
me just get a layup ggressive here's
mudiay put the bass up both to that hand
away from the Dean is over the shoulder
and watch the digits over the shoulder
boom oh my goodness hey one hand slinger
from the Yoker stop are you looking into
yoga it's the facilitator folks this is
a seven footer I mean you just you don't
see this kind of a building from this
big of a guy Humphreys around everybody
missed it here comes the okage yoga's
dump it yes Millsaps here's that play a
while ago bounce pass not look and now
some he'll be out until probably the
fourth quarter believe I said that tie
to season is yoga change the rebound
[Applause]
the game assists shame on put it back
hit the reach-in over the top in the
middle foot of the woods to Grandma's
house we're going channelers incredible
grandma it's me it's not the big bad
woman it's me
[Music]
you got the youngsters first basket a
night in a heart heart cut the shoulder
is written in perfect lays out in front
of him oh pardon this is the beer is
Murray you go Ozzie Nelson letting it
fly look my target was way short the lab
upstairs to parade here in London
[Applause]
I'll Farid for hanging on the rim
justice said though look at the no-look
pass three we swung a little bit but why
not after a brilliant pass like that
well he got promptitude when you get
buff and you tug and they usually let
you hang on it toku you
he's got 12 more
and Nicola yo conspirators his first
Pass
leads to triple-double which the
playoffs possibly and possibly playing
against the Warriors in the first round
[Applause]
that's a great pass not a big fellow
right there you read that all the way I
love his patience more big man in the
post great pass right there three guys
on you make your teammates better
oh good screen by yogic just buried that
is behind the back to Chandler it was
actually over the head to Chandler and a
score mo as sweet as it gets Nicoli
okage doing his thing Wilson Chandler
and Gary Harris doing their thanks
coming back to Bankers Life Fieldhouse
[Applause]
front of the pending calls on the other
side this Watson quick tap just a
heads-up play that's where you know
you're G once he knows where his
teammates it's not everybody look at him
he's already tapped it into the magic
for 16 turnover charge to the Denver
Nuggets
a lot of attention to here they got this
still on the help of Booker there it is
whoop right behind the back to bees one
dribble finishes Nuggets were down by
six the back to Chandler now perfect you
see no one there paying attention the
second time he's got double to one guy
does a good job of Lau's don't just
stand in there I saw on highlights one
time Larry Byrd says powering it up no
yoga jazz it there's a reset on the 20
Lyle's scores where did that pass come
from not sure I did
there it is an incredible dish
[Applause]
careful now five to shoot back game is
confidence now Nicoli opens don't work
on deadly gonna power it up behind the
back Lyle's off the glass yes oh what a
password hey beautiful
no look behind the back pass for Nicoli
opens his assist account started it and
then watch this long pass he didn't even
get it to the other hand
Jinju gets trying to find their
offensive rhythm here nicola on the
drive pass it great pass to morris who
knocks it in the floppy floater flew out
of bounds water polo class Beasley
how about that for your gift assist and
watch his kids assist up a turnover
BeeZee doesn't run Minnesota fell asleep
Liggins nearly got there but third
rebound
for Scott yep and it's pretty well
defended Jackson right near D to the
horses if Jackson realized what's coming
yeah he's trying to stay on this body
actually jumps but how about not having
an assist yet in the game and your foot
Torrey Craig maybe get back in this ball
game
[Applause]
[Music]
so pretty he sees him
the Reid Sadler once again see how the
weak side goes asleep and you just get a
cutter weak side goes to sleep the
smallest guy in the floor he cuts the
basket gets a layup
[Applause]
that's by Nicola yoga did all the Barney
said they're worried about juggler the
ball that just no looks integrand
instead of standing out somewhere else
once he's got Jackson watching Joker so
he just attacks the basket
Martin give it to your kids
you just never know what's gonna happen
Jory Craig not only does he block and
crispy saves it at the am which was big
then watch his past he just drops it off
to Torre Miami he one of the surprises
of the season fourth place and east
[Applause]
yogic with the set up for Simmons
what's the rebound and in the window I
mean that's just over the defendants
hand maybe Larry if Larry's an install
it never touches his second half my
answer Matt it's just that's a crazy
past what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content